so what they're doing is 75% of this
multi-million dollar program is going to
try to change a behavior that doesn't
actually cause any accidents
hi i'm tim cavanaugh a recent TV
we're here with J Bieber who has been
fighting the City and County of Los
Angeles over red-light cameras
J welcome thank you good to be here not
identified as a as a folk hero for your
efforts to and the red light camera
regime can you just give us a little
idea of what's going on and what you
what has been accomplished I think the
biggest accomplishment that we've had so
far is that the Police Commission which
is a five-member civilian review board
they have decided on a 5 to 0 vote to
end of the red light camera program and
about oh I guess about five six months
ago they were all in favor of the
program so in that time from my efforts
in providing them with information and
they're very thoughtful group of people
they're not politicians they're
appointed and and they're you know
they're really there were really a great
group of people and they and they looked
at this issue from a scientific point of
view from an economic point of view and
they decided that it wasn't worth
continuing and now there's pushback from
that I'm having a little trouble
following the economics because we read
that it for a five-year extension of the
project would be a budget impact of 15
million all so that a hundred thousand
people have gotten tickets these tickets
are about four hundred fifty dollars
each and yet the city manages to lose a
million dollars a year on it how is that
possible there's a number of reasons
first of all the costs in running the
program are extensive the contract
itself at least a proposed contract
would have been over three million
dollars a year to put to have these red
light cameras at these 32 intersections
here in the city and the city has like
4,600 intersections so where it's a very
small impact overall in terms of the
city in terms of what it could possibly
do in terms of safety but it cost the
city you know three million dollars plus
just for the contract then there's a
bout of almost a million dollars in the
cost of the police for their time and
efforts to sit behind a desk and click
on mouse and and get people tickets all
day long and go to port and then and
then in terms of the revenue that comes
back from the tickets you know it's a
it's almost a $500 ticket here in less
Angeles in the state of California and
not very much of that goes to the city
the state takes a very large chunk of
that and the and then the county takes
some and then the courts take some so
all told the city gets probably less
than a hundred and fifty bucks or so per
ticket in most cases if there were
traffic cop there you probably wouldn't
see a ticket issued in the first place
it's rolling right turns that's correct
yeah the rolling right turn is 75
percent of the tickets and the citations
that are given we did a study because
there's has been this argument as you
know is a rolling right turn dangerous
and we did a study on that and we looked
at the database from the California
Highway Patrol that has all the
accidents in the state of California and
we looked at Los Angeles specifically
and we found that it's extremely rare
that an accident will occur for a
rolling right turn so what they're doing
is seventy-five percent of this
multi-million dollar program is going to
try to change a behavior that doesn't
actually cause any accidents it's more
or less a judgment call to I mean this
is a California as a right turn on red
state as my thinking probably most
states are at this point and it you know
this is the issue is it's just turned
and you never really come to a complete
stop you're already halfway through you
make the turn I did it twice on the way
to work another thing you found in in in
your studies and then I think there was
a 2008 study to back us up was that
there is a case to be made that red
light cameras actually increase the
number of accidents can you expand yeah
that's true that red light cameras have
been shown in a number of cases to
increase rear-end collisions and the
reason for that is that when a driver
approaches an intersection where there's
a red light camera they may react in an
unusual way so they may slam on their
brakes for example and then the argument
is well the person should've been
following them so closely but on the
other hand if somebody slams on the
brakes in front of you how much of that
is your fault the other thing that's
that's dangerous about them from an
accident standpoint is that some people
will speed up and try to speed through
the intersection because they're trying
not to get that ticket as opposed to
trying to drive safely unless they're
those are just sometimes not exactly the
same things what's a better way to
assume that that you know I'm not gonna
volunteer anything but let's assume we
all agree that people shouldn't be
running red lights and so what's the
best way to get that under control a
large part of red light running and and
I like to sort of call it red light
incursions because basically what
happens is at the very end of the yellow
and the light turns red that's exactly
where all these violations are occurring
there they're like eighths of a second
quarter of a second violations I mean
there's these are very technical
violations of people misjudging exactly
when the light is going to change and
the way that you deal with that is you
lengthen your yellow light what you want
to do is you want to make sure your
yellow light conforms to a particular
scientific formula and you're supposed
to use the speed of the approaching
traffic and a lot of case like here in
Los Angeles or in the state of
California they use the posted speed
limit which is not necessarily the
actual speed of the traffic approaching
the intersection so if you lengthen your
yellow light and we've seen this in
every single case where it's happening
the city of Loma Linda they lengthen
their yellow lights by one second and
they saw over a ninety percent drop in
violations the very next day so what
does that tell you that tells you 90
some odd percent of violations don't
have to happen if you have a long enough
yellow light the other thing to do is to
make sure you have what's called an all
red phase and that means that the the
light is red in all direction so if
somebody does miss the end of the yellow
and get and go into the red the cross
traffic hasn't started so you're not
going to have an accident and that's the
- those are the two things that you can
do that will improve your intersection
safety the most what's your big
technical hurdle in explaining this to
people and explaining it to the the
police commission in a way that they
could eventually not only understand but
change their minds we're a very science
based organization safer streets la but
there's you don't have a science
background you're not used to thinking
you know in logical terms you're
thinking in emotional terms like for
example oh we have to stop red light
running to save the children you know
that kind of thing and that's usually
the argument from the other side but
it's not about that it's about the
science and what actually causes
inadvertent red light running and then
the really serious kinds of red light
running which is for example somebody
who's distracted or somebody who is
impaired or somebody who is fatigued or
somebody's fleeing the police those are
the kinds of things that actually caused
the really serious
red line running accidents and those
things are not going to be affected by a
red-light camera it's really only
somebody who might say oh I think I can
make it and then they they don't so
trying to explain that and explain the
science behind it it's really the
biggest hurdle you've won the science
argument with regard to the police board
and you've won the economic argument
because the city controller Wendy Greuel
has issued a statement saying that the
city's losing a million dollars a year
there's still a big political hurdle you
know it's interesting because people
hate red light cameras everywhere in the
country that these have come up for a
vote
they have been voted down by usually
very very large margin so there's no
argument that can be made that the
public is in favor of red light cameras
I think the only argument can be made is
that you know the public is somewhat
apathetic if they don't live in an area
that has them or they haven't gotten a
ticket themselves so sort of motivating
people to speak out and we've been
fairly successful in doing that is not
as easy as it would otherwise be people
have lives and they have got a good work
and they they got to live their lives
and it's interesting to me how the
politicians don't recognize the the
groundswell of opposition that's
actually out there on the somewhat under
the surface and I think they're gonna be
unpleasantly surprised that when they do
run for higher office that this issues
going to come back and bite them very
very hard